the nation's capital welcomes
an honored veteran who comes
back to his job on Veterans Day November 11
president Ike has won his greatest battle to the
relief of millions who value his great leadership
events a grave president states America's position
United States was not consulted in any way about
any phase of these actions nor were we informed
of them in advance in the circumstances I have
described there will be no United States
involvement in these present hostilities I
therefore have no plan to call the Congress in
special session in the past the United Nations
has proved able to find a way to end bloodshed we
believe it can and that it will do so again in a
time of world crisis America went to the polls
in almost record numbers it returned President
Eisenhower to office with a nine million
morality the president made this pledge
with whatever strength there is within I will
continue and so will my associates to do just
one thing to work for 168 million Americans
here at home and for peace in the world